assalamualaikum warahmatullah here two
brothers and sisters and dear friends
may the peace of blessing of God
Almighty be upon your goal now today
we're going to be talking about a very
important topic sliding sliding is known
for many things you could the definition
for slide is on the screen as you can
see you can slide on ice you can slide
on snow you can slide on a slippery road
but when you slide into a man's DMS
things can get heated
so guys today's talk is gonna be about
sliding sliding it's people's DMS now
what I mean by that is another time the
purpose of this is mainly men men are
known to go into sisters the ends
message is I love you are all this kind
of nonsense all these kind of promises
just to get one thing but to promise or
main get sisters sliding in or girls
sliding into the diems yes they do and
this is why I'm going to be talking to
you about today and I'm going to show
you some of the experiences that I have
had and how I feel with it and I'm going
to be talking to you about why this
happens going to be talking about the
psychology of man how a man can be
affected by this I'm gonna talk a bit
about my personal experience and some
evil woman and there's evil men as well
now guys first of all to start off with
is a lines messenger yes okay because
this is what we try to live by and those
are the ones Allah as mister is who we
obey Allah has taught is very clearly
and Proxima Salaam has said that the
biggest thing that I fear for my Ummah
is the fitna of woman yeah and also we
know in the firaga hospital has said
that the fitna the the proteins are
planning of Shaitaan is dying
is weak and the protein and planning of
a woman is having now by Eve means we
are the means great now this does not
mean woman are like evil okay this does
not make women evil he's talking about
certain types of woman and if they want
to plot that they can plot and meaning
that a man's biggest weakness is a woman
so when you are with to something this
doesn't make the person like the
they evil this doesn't mean that it
means a woman if you have a witness to
us ice creams
it doesn't make ice cream evil it just
means you have a witness to us ice cream
dreams and say and no I'm not bloody
trying to say ice cream and woman are no
I'm not talking about for the mother for
example okay so we know that also our
sisters in the Koran that the first
calamity or the first fitna to hit below
israel the children israel was woman
yeah and we know from youtube and it's
around that he even mentioned in the
quran that i feel it wasn't for allah
subhanho wa taala he may have fallen for
that and this goes for every single one
of us as men well i these missions that
we can don't think we it doesn't you
know it's not a fitna for us you know
it's something of course it is but we
seek refuge in allah and we ask allah to
make us among those who are protected
from this and do not for the for for the
traps so cutting the long story short
let's go straight to to slide in yeah
into the DMS and let's see what happens
okay you look so it'll react to it okay
now the first one that I've got not the
first one one of the ones that'll call I
get a lot yeah I've had people sending
me nudes
I've had people sending you all kinds of
disgusting stuff seen disgusting stuff
etc this is one that I received and let
both of them to because I believe
they're fit perfectly clowns or just
sisters with evil agendas which one
which one come to later Ali will you
marry me sounds romantic
I said I won't even sister I'm already
married she drops evidence here in
direct your you are an out more than one
life yes we know in this town we are not
more than one wife and hamdullah it's a
practice that is from allah subhanaw
taala and it start not only by muslims a
lot of non-muslim do as well back
Christians or Jews or Mormons do it as
well and to be honest there's even
non-muslims who are not religious to it
they just called there any stop you have
a second wife they tend to call it side
chicks and mistresses on the side that
they use in abuse Islam has come to
regulate in a right way and give the
second wife of the third or the fourth
wife and right to treat her honorably
and Maria are going to a parents
not using her for material games so
handle it it's a practice that me hunter
you can say okay as a Mandy I'm happy
about it know whatever it may be whether
smile one's messenger we hear and we
obey and obviously this doesn't mean
that he broke Scalia but probably just
tried to fix up do your Salah P is the
card do the fat first before you come to
the sooner actions in Charlotte so
brothers don't get excited
and also the Prophet SAW Allah and we'll
send them said a man he has who has two
wives and treats one better than the
other but their judgment will come
leaning on one side so this is not
matter
that's joking talking to a second wife
here just a reminder anyway so what I'm
sure because of that the next one that
I've got what I think I'm in love with
you and just need your help but I'll
speak to you soon insha'Allah stay safe
okay obviously says that you're using
insha'Allah if Allah wills and then you
say and I'm in love with you you can't
get to Haram say something around with
her on top it's not right I understand
your point of view but it's not the
right way to approach it you know that
it's not the right way to go about it
okay so next one do I get a second
chance
walaikum Salaam with what I said getting
to know you know me for what for
marriage I'm already married drops the
evidence again but you can have a second
it's not that easy I'm not buying a pair
of tomatoes or just gonna buy another
tomato
I'm not saying woman or tomatoes by the
way guys please just let's just be you
know I don't want to learn and I might
want especially famous ones now this is
a sister who this is some sister who's
been stalking me yeah okay
and I've warned of many times yeah and
I'm doing this video from grace which I
expose anyone yet Ali I need you to
acknowledge me I'm worried I'm going to
have another year of waiting for
something that won't happen I didn't see
anything happening job I also don't want
to go back to my job I don't want to be
at home
blah blah blah I love you and II and you
just want to be able to sleep and not
feel so jittery and hyper alert I feel
like I'm going crazy
may Allah make it easy to stop and this
one ones I bought Salaam alaikum
how can I hope so she sent something she
was that how are you yeah how are you
the way she spoke how
spelling mistake or how it looks like
meal from different country the fake
account you know haecheol w not hey JW
not how it's how are you I said good
that she said to heart okay why are you
sending me that yeah so sometimes you
have to be a bit firm do don't chance it
cause it to show that when I hit the
mess when I'm not here to you know flow
you're saying another one that I got
high love hot hello bye leave me alone
and others that we get probably faking
cancer that's it hello it's okay hi how
can I help how are you doing good
another one how come I said I'm gonna
come I love you good night I love you
honey
I was crying today I love you I love you
me always wanted a protection I mean if
we believe in our love we should do
things the right way so as you can see
guys that these are some of the messages
out yet yeah and to be honest I know
some of them are trolls I know some of
them might be genuine in a way where
sometimes you do get people are bit
obsessive for whatever reason it may be
and I'm going to mock them or something
like that you know just may I look you
to someone that's good for you you do
you I'm trying to say but the thing here
that I want to mention is that a lot of
the time people actually have evil
agendas but there's actually sisters out
there who actually do this on purpose
they actually do some person but a
purpose some sisters yeah no we don't
want to generalize a little to every
sister the same and these sisters what
they do is they have an agenda so what
if it may be they might be hurt for some
reason someone did something whatever it
may be so they hate all men yeah they're
hate all men and what they do is
specifically us they try to nebari yeah
I'm gonna you know they're hypocrites
are they like these these dour guys or
whatever it may be just in general not
just our guys it so what they do is they
try to trap us and they send these dirty
messages these dirty pictures these
filthy things or even try in subtle ways
your message i'll but i need advice and
we try to advise and then they'll try to
add a little bit of Laurel and a little
smiley face and a little bit Vista just
as slowly you know and they're plotting
and let me tell you guys something yet
while he you guys I call
evil people you guys are the most evil
people ever you know why because you
know very clearly as a man look I'm a
man yeah and as a man I know people
think oh if you're a religious figure
this that all automatically you're
immune to the fitna of woman a woman
though they fix you or - this is
absolutely nonsense and rubbish I'm
still a man when I start doing Dawa or
start doing whatever I love okay I don't
care about no I'm still human being I'm
still gonna be weak but at the same time
that does not give anyone an excuse
especially those in the Dawa especially
with no religious stuff to take
advantage of your platform and mess
sisters around no way it doesn't all I'm
just pointing out is that men are weak
and their sisters who are doing this to
take advantage as well as there is
brothers who do certain things take
advantage of sisters it works both ways
but sometimes it's made out to be that
the corporates are only brothers most of
the time it is known for this but most
of the time people make it seem like
it's only men know we suffer from this
we have evil sisters I'll call their
evil sisters yet who do this and you
guys are more to blame if you message
somebody whoever it may be and you're
talking about a flirtatious where this
that knowing very well that they are
weak to this they are weak to women in
general any man no son of a doubt you
are more to blame you know what because
you are messaging messaging there with a
plot and plan to take them to expose
them yeah that manual messaging if he
forcefully a trap he's turning out of
weakness and desire weakness and desire
which she should feel one shouldn't do
in the first place anyway he's done that
out of weakness and desire yeah you are
more to blame for protein and planning
you both are wrong but the fact that you
did that on purpose
you are more wrong yeah so that's why
for example in astound we have something
called if you cause somebody if you did
so somebody's mother you get a sin yeah
okay
you get the sin of in statute insulting
your own mother you know why because we
knew and saw that person's mother
they're gonna end up it's sorting your
mother back and you're the reason you're
the cause of that if you did not say
that he would not say that so you are
more to blame same way Allah tells us
not to insult that idols the pagan gods
because if you do that they're gonna end
up the Sultan Allah with ignorance
you can translate their gods are nothing
they stop insulting Allah Allah is the
true God do you hear me trying to say so
that's why Allah has told us not to
insult other gods you came China Sea so
that's why same thing with the prophets
when you instigate and try to plot and
plan against the sister to trap and use
the abuser while I allow you I more in
trouble because you use that sister's
emotions and her weaknesses to drag her
in you use that if you didn't do that
that wouldn't happen both parties are to
be but you are to be interpret some plan
against it so I just want to see that
fear all of us to find our allah to the
sisters that are watching this and
trying to trap us because she'll tell
you something
yeah when these things happened i've got
somebody else not just hitting me news
yeah and i talk and feel or support i
said well i said what are you getting
out of doing this i said as a female is
this the only thing that you have to
offer your body your human people have a
mind but i have an internet don't have a
personality a character something good
about you why do you just treat trust
your backside and your chest size or
whatever it may be you don't have more
to offer as a woman you are a human
being don't exercise turn you to some
sexual like oh you can offer is the way
your body looks and your lips look this
big and that big and you're changing
your body what happened is i think they
facetiming by accident
yeah and then what did is I accepted it
just to see and when I did that I
screenshot today and they start crying
and they start please bravado and expose
enough said I am just scare them as I'm
gonna make this public to warm people
against people like you and I start
crying this time I'm sorry
so there's evil people with evil nature
so brothers and sisters this was just a
little message for me to you guys to be
careful yeah brothers and sisters you
know a man's weakness is a female fear
Allah don't use that against it don't
use that against him because you
their judgment and when it comes to
sliding please try not to slide towards
my DMS because you're gonna slide right
back out you know I'm saying and that's
about it that's about it guys
take care good bye